it's time to play the game right you
guys I think that's that we should do I
think it's time for these guys to win
some money we've got Josette and Mick we
got all our Hollyweird squares this is
gonna be fun
remember squares these guys are playing
for $2,000 a game so you make sure that
you really put some thought into these
questions and now because there's no
other reason I think Mick is going first
right you're gonna pick a square that's
Mike sir oh sorry I don't know it just
says my K and I get confused all right
what celebrity gonna pick remember wendy
is the center square let's go with Wendy
Wendy
smart strategy when do you play
tic-tac-toe I don't know Wendy you awake
yes right this is great Wendy if the
president dies who takes over if the
president dies who takes oh god Mike
what do you want to agree with Wendy or
do you want to disagree I'm gonna have
to disagree well Mike you're right it's
actually Wendy it's not god takes over
it's the vice president you've heard of
that
watching Freddy cougar Wendy a very good
job by the way Mike okay you're on the
board you've got the center acts and
let's go to Josette Josette you got to
get in the game who do you pick Nikki
Nikki beautiful Nikki sexy beautiful
Nikki Glaser who's got Lenny going wild
over in this book absolutely how
exciting it's just a career highlight
for you Nikki to be on the house it
truly is right I love these people yeah
Nikki true or false in Japan December
25th is celebrated as national [ __ ]
day okay
guess we know in Japan's period as the
flag does look like period sheets
a [ __ ] day I'm gonna go that is so
absurd
I'm gonna go true true you say in Japan
December 25th they celebrate national
[ __ ] day Josette is that true I
disagree
you think it's false yeah you happen to
be right it is false national [ __ ]
day in Japan is celebrated every year on
July 21st so there is a there is a
[ __ ] day what all right how many
movies had that you've been in that I
might have seen not any big-budget ones
yet I just did some local stuff in New
Jersey with the company called intimacy
Productions another one called facial
abuse yeah they're in East Orange New
Jersey's we're actually the first
companies ever shot me